[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
nous sommes le lundi 30 octobre voici
les titres quelle mesure prendre après
les émeutes de l'été dernier ce vendredi
27 octobre la première ministre était en
déplacement à Chantelou lesévg pour un
comité interministériel des villes
ellisabeth borne a dévoilé plusieurs
mesures pour répondre aux difficultés
des quartiers populaires ce déplacement
était également l'occasion pour la chef
du gouvernement et ses ministres
d'échanger avec les élus du département
touchés par les émeutes join avant
Halloween en pleines vacances de la
toussin halloween approche à grand pas
pour l'occasion la rédaction de tv78
vous propose des idées de sorti
effrayante dans les viblines de quoi
déjà vous plonger dans l'ambiance et de
retour à montboron pour un match les
joueurs du FC Versailles se sont
inclinés ce samedi face au FC Fleury 91
malgré le soutien des supporters les
versaillers se sont fait éliminer de la
Coupe de France après une séance de tir
au but le résumé de la rencontre à
suivre dans cette
édition et puis l'invité du 78 le
département des Yvelines a remis son
bilan de fréquentation touristique
estival 2023 et il est positif avec des
perspectives encourageantes pour 2024
avec nous pour en parler la viceprés
président des ivlin délégué à la culture
et au tourisme Joséphine Colm berger
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors
nous ferons le point en deuxème partie
d'émission sur cette hausse de la
fréquentation estivale ainsi que
l'initiative voulue par le Département
d'un tourisme plus durable avec nous
également un journaliste de la rédaction
de tv78 Michel elmidoro bonsoir bonsoir
on parlera avec vous de l'actualité
sportive dans le département mais aussi
des derniers résultats
sportifs
mais avant ça je vous en parlais dans
les titres ce vendredi 27 octobre la
première ministre ellisabeth born s'est
rendue à Chantelou levvin pour un comité
interministériel des villes une visite
qui interent intervient après les
émeutes urbaines de l'été et durant
laquelle Elisabeth born a dévoilé des
mesures pour répondre aux difficultés
des quartiers populaires un reportage à
voir de Régine ralèche et Julien
Leroi donc voilà donc ça c'est
déminéralisé et vous allez voir ici
c'était c'était en fait des parkings et
tout ça c'est vrai donner un nouveau
visage au quartier populaire la première
ministre ellizabeth borne s'était rendue
ce vendredi 27 octobre à Chantelou les
vignes une déambulation à la rencontre
des habitants et des commerçants avec
des mesures pour améliorer le quotidien
des populations mixtité sociale
transition écologique ou emploi au
lendemain des annonces du gouvernement
sur la sécurité après les émeutes de cet
été la mè chantelouvaise partageait son
enthousiasme un accent particulier sera
mis sur l'écologie avec davantage d'
investissement pour notamment s'adapter
au changement climatique la transition
énergétique qui n'avait jamais été
retenue comme priorité dans nos
quartiers alors que c'est l'endroit où
il fait le plus chaud en été le plus
Frid en hiver et que les habitants ont
eu des augmentations de charges
considérables alors que c'est c'est ceux
dont on sait très bien qui coûtte le
moins cher qui sont les moins pollueurs
et qui mais par contre qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de gérer leurs propres
économies donc là 15 % du fond vert sur
nos quartier c'est ce qu'on avait
demandé ça c'est une attention
particulière tendre vers le plein emploi
une phase de test sera menée dès 2024
pour lutter contre les pratiques
discriminatoires envers les populations
des quartiers populaires objectif
permettre un meilleur accès au stagees
ou à l'embauche pour soutenir
l'entrepreneuriat davantage de moyens
seront alloués avec 456 millions d'euros
débloqués sur 4 ans c'est un peu le
fantasme de de l'habitant de banlieu qui
sait faire son
auto-entreprise moi je ne crois pas qu'à
ça je crois à la formation beaucoup à
l'apprentissage beaucoup et si on donne
pas un zoom un zoom extraordinaire sur
la formation et l'apprentissage on ne
développera pas la la capacité des
jeunes d'aller chercher l'emploi où ils
veulent avec une avec un métier qu'ils
ont rencontré par passion au cours de sa
visite ellisabeth borne a aussi
découvert le site de la future cité
éducative Simon veille de Chantelou
Lévin qui devrait voir le jour en 2025
école médiathèque et centre de loisir
rassemblé au sein d'un campus
pluridisciplinaire pour aider à la
réussite des enfants la première
ministre a annoncé le développement de
ce type de projet à d'autres communes
une façon de faire de l'éducation un
levier contre les inégalités sociales
le point maintenant sur le reste de
l'actualité dans les
ivelines et c'est avec vous Michel el
midoro malgré la pluie qui ne cesse de
tomber la préfecture des ivblines
prolonge l'arrêté concernant les
restriction de l'usage de l'eau et oui
Gabriel est ce jusqu'au 31 décembre la
sécheresse exceptionnelle de l'hiver
2022 et de l'été 2023 a entraîné une
vidange des nappes fréatiques la nappe
de brevval par exemple du côté de
montajolie est toujours en situation de
crise elle n'arrive pas à se recharger
malgré les dernières averses ainsi la
zone centre desin est en situation de
crise le reste du département se trouve
lui en situation de vigilance pour Rael
les habitants qui se trouvent dans la
zone d'alerte maximale ont interdiction
d'arroser leurs pelouses leur potager ou
même de remplir leur piscine je pense
que ça devrait aller en ce moment on en
a pas vraiment besoin Gabriel ouis
effectivement en ce moment ça devrait
aller direction coinière maintenant où
l'implantation d'un pylone est contesté
il s'agit d'un pylone de 18 m de hauteur
de la société FreeMobile son objectif
assurer une meilleure couverture réseau
cependant le maire de la commune Didier
Fischer conteste son implantation car ce
dernier se trouverit à proximité d'une
crèche le maire a également déclaré nous
ne nous opposons pas au projet de
FreeMobile néanmoins par principe de
précaution afin de préserver la qualité
paysagère nous avons refusé le lieu
d'implantation proposé malgré plusieurs
discussions avec la ville l'opérateur ne
souhaite pas revoir l'emplacement de ce
pylone freemobil a donc engagé un
recours au tribunal administratif de
Versailles on poursuit ces informations
Michel avec de la bière mdine yvine on
vous en avez déjà parlé l'année dernière
dans les ivines une brasse se brasse une
bière sans% artisanal baptisé la petite
sœur elle est située à sartrouille au
sein de cette brasserie Vanessa Collin
la jeune fille de 20 ans a confectionné
une bière ambrée à la carotte et
attention Gabrielle grâce à cette
recette elle est devenue la meilleure
apprentie brasseuse de France était à
l'occasion de la 11e cérémonie des
rabelés des jeunes talents de la
gastronomie à retenir également Michel
l'élection du Mister île-defance ça
avait lieu ce weekend et parmi les 14
candidats deux ivelinois originaires de
trappe et de vézyi vill coublé
participer comme Martin Auberger on
écoute son interview au micro de Jessie
willin de nos confrères de radio
sensation alors je vais défendre la
santé mentale euh de chaque individu je
vais pousser les gens à aller de l'avant
à croire en eux et avoir confiance en
eux donc on va voir ce que ça va donner
c'est finalement Rémy Ducro qui a été
sacré le plus beau garçon de la région
mais alors qui est Rémy Ducro Gabriel
c'est un Parisien originaire du Nord il
tentait pour la seconde fois d'accéder
au titre régional le jeune homme de 27
ans est gestionnaire d'actif immobilier
pour une grande enseigne française de
bricolage et de décoration on écoute sa
réaction déjà je peux dire que je suis
très fier de représenter notre belle
région
l'île-de-fance j'espère que je serai à
la hauteur moi la cause que je choisis
de défendre c'est la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire on a encore
beaucoup trop de personnes en France qui
qui subissent ça aujourd'hui en 2023 et
pour moi c'est pas normal faut qu'on
arrive à à dépasser ça et à et à aider
tout le monde passionné de natation et
de musculation il a désormais quelques
mois pour se préparer pour l'élection
nationale de Mister France 2024 elle
aura lieu le 17 février à re mal maison
dans les hautes scènes merci beaucoup
Michel pour toutes ces informations et
si vous aussi vous voyez une information
ou une image qui retient votre attention
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager avec le
hashtag 7
news sorcièrees zombies ou encore Vampir
viendront peut-être toquer à votre porte
demain soir et pour cause c'est déjà
Halloween pour l'occasion le 78 vous
propose son top 3 des événements à ne
pas rater dans les Yvelines les
suggestions d'Aurélie l'a
fait
le château de bretil ouvre ses portes
aux adeptes des Nimes sanglantes une
Murder Party animée par deux comédiens
vous feront vivre dans les années 20
pendant 2 Hees pour comprendre ce qu'il
est arrivé à la comptesse
nunatique petit sorciers Vampir et
autres monstres seront attendus à
l'espace Philippe Noiré aux clés sous-
boois pour hallowen les animations
gratuites seront prévues pour toute la
famille au programme maquillage activité
manuelle escape game et chasse aux
bonbons et ce n'est pas tout un
spectacle terrifiant est prévu pour
18h30 d'étranges monstres s'installent
dans le parc de France Miniature ils ont
volé les bijoux de la reine alionos de
la citrouille des indices sont
dissimulés dans les monuments et retenus
par ces drôles de créatures en
participant au jeux de piste vous
aiderez la reine à retrouver le voleur
le billet adulte et enfant est à 20
€.
allez c'est l'heure de parler sport dans
le
[Musique]
78 et l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est avec vous Michael
elmidoro on commence par du football on
joué ce weekend le 6e tour de la Coupe
de France exilé depuis deux saisons au
stade jeanoin à Paris le FC versaill
recevait dans son stade historique Moron
l'équipe de Fleury malgré le soutien de
leurs support porter les Versaillais se
sont inclinés lors de la séance de tir
au but le résumé du match les images de
Clara de
Frutos de retour au stade maoboron pour
la Coupe de France le FC Versailles qui
évolue en National avait à cœur de
gagner contre fleur 91 devant les 1000
spectateurs présents pour ce 6e tour en
première période les Versaillais
dominent et poussent mais n'arrivent pas
à trouver la faille malgré la division
d'écart le score à la pause 0 à0 je
pense qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
d'occasions voilà sauf que il faut qu'on
arrive à les mettre au fond être plus
juste à concrétiser le nombre incroyable
qu'on a eu de situation pour être dans
une scénario plus confortable au retour
des vestiaires Versailles attaque se
procure des occasions et marque enfin la
69e minute par l'International haïtien
Mondi prunier 1 à0 mais l'avantage sera
de courte durée 4 minutes plus tard
Fleury égalis suite à cette tête de
Freddy Colombo un partout malgré
plusieurs opportunités et un but refusé
pour les joueurs de la cité royale le
score n'évoluera pas direction la séance
de tir but dans cet exercice ce sont les
essoniens qui l'emportent 5 à 4 versaill
demi-finaliste de la Coupe de France en
2022 sort dès le 6e tour je suis très
agacé parce
que c'est un scénario qui se répète
depuis 4 C matchs au niveau de
l'ouverture du score sur ce match là on
a raté beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de situations voilà on doit
être beaucoup plus efficace dans tout ce
qu'on fait en ce moment donc faut se
taire et et se mettre à Bousser av une
exigence un peu plus importante le FC
Versailles devra se replonger rapidement
dans le quotidien du championnat de
Nationale les ivinois 9e du classement
joueront dès ce vendredi 3 novembre à
19h30 sur le terrain de Dijon et Michael
si Versailles est éliminé de cette Coupe
de France l'aventure continue pour un
club ivelinois ou il a réussi à
s'imposer sur le terrain découant ce
dimanche à l'occasion de ce 6e tour de
la Coupe de France où le club de R1 est
donc parti pour faire un parcours dans
cette compétition et aura la lourde
tâche de représenter les ivin lors du du
prochain match puisque la 3ème équipe
ivelinoise engagé Chatou a perdu 2-0 sur
le terrain de torsy les rencontres du 7e
tour se disputeront ce dimanche 19
novembre on va descendre de quelques
divisions pour parler du championnat de
D1 de district on joué ce weekend pour
le compte de la 5e journée du
championnat poissi nouveaux
pensionnaires dans cette division s'est
imposé 1-0 sur le terrain d'ardriourt
les Mureau gagnent à domicile contre
marli Leroi 3-1 bayinoisi s'arrache pour
venir à bout de ouille so 3-2 un partout
entre voisin et l'équipe 3 du FC mois de
he pour le chaîner à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de Rambouillet enfin Chatou 2
écrase moropa 7 à1 au classement
Conflant est premier devant les Mureau
et binoisi et on continue par du basket
dans le championnat de National 3 ce
samedi soir trappe s'est imposé 88 à 78
face à grav gravelg grandfort dans la
même poule l'entente le chîn Versailles
s'est fait écraser 112 à 45 à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de ardre et
Chatou a perdu contre Saint-Thomas
basket au classement les trapises sont
9e sur 14 le LC CV 78 est avant-dernier
et Chatou est bon dernier toujours en
basket Michel Victor wembaniama continue
son apprentissage de la NBA deux
défaites en trois matchs de NBA pour
livinois Victor wembanama son équipe des
SAN anonio Spurs a perdu sur le terrain
des Los Angeles clipper sur le score de
123 à 83 le natif du chénero cancour n'a
pas vraiment brillé avec 11 points et 5
rebonds pendant la partie il a aussi
perdu 5 ballons le joueur de 2 M23 aura
l'occasion de se rattraper dès ce
mercredi 1er novembre les Spurs joueront
sur le terrain des Suns de phénix et en
hand bal maintenant les féminines de
Montini le bretonux jouent ce weekend
jouent ce weekend pardon jouer ce
weekend dans le championnat de National
2 Montini le bretonux n'a pas réussi à
renverser le leader Rosière Saint-Julien
sur son terrain les inis monages se sont
inclinés 36 à 30 à domicile malgré les 9
buts de Sean Gomis au classement les
cinentinois sont à la 8e place avec 12
points à 9 points de leur adversaire du
soir un mot de voile à présent la classe
imoka n'a pas pu prendre le départ de la
16e édition de la Transat Jacques Vabre
ce dimanche nos deux ivelinois éc bon et
Louis Burton sont pour l'instant restés
à K Havre la raison une mer très agitée
avec de fortes rafales de vent des
conditions météorologiques difficiles
qui ont contraint les organisateurs à
décaler le départ des imoka vers la
Martinique pour l'instant aucune date de
départ n'a été reprogrammée et nos
navigateurs iminois patientent gentiment
au Havre on écoute la réaction du
skippper versaill Éric Bellon de
stanazwan on était prêt à partir sachant
que ça allait être super dur moi j'étais
habillé quand j'ai eu la nouvelle
j'étais habillé pour partir en mer donc
voilà de toute façon on y allait en
disant que ça allait être compliqué mais
qu'on allait tout faire pour que ça
passe et là le fait que ça s'arrête
évidemment la première réaction
c'est c'est ouf voilà parce que
l'attention c'est jamais agréable moi je
d
mal c'est je je suis tendu voilà puis
moi j'aime pas être tendu comme plein de
gens c'est la première réaction c'est
réaction assez agréable de se dire bon
bah finalement on va pas la guerre voilà
après il y a la
déception au total une quarantaine
d'imoka participent à cette course
transatlantique enfin pour terminer un
tournoi de football ce weekend était
organisé la 3e édition de la Challenge
Cup à plaisir au programme 32 équipes
avec des joueurs de moins de 12 ans se
sont affronté au stade de Bernard Girou
des images de Mélanie Poky c'est l'un
des tournois les plus prestigieux dans
la catégorie des moins de 12 ans en
France la Challenge Cup de plaisir était
organisée pendant 2 jours ce samedi 28
et dimanche 29 octobre au stade Bernard
Girou ce rendez-vous est très attendu
chaque année par les amoureux du
ballonrond c'est un événement qui permet
de rassembler ça permet en fait de
rassembler toutes les tous les amoureux
du football autour d'un d'un même but la
passion des joueurs la passion du public
et des
encadrants donc c'est un moyen de
rassembler et d'apporter de la joiee et
de la bonne humeur le tournoi prend en
ampleur de 24 il est passé aujourd'hui à
32 équipes on retrouve sur le terrain
des clubs professionnels comme les
Belges de Bruges le Red Star les Anglais
de Norwich ou encore l'Olympique
Lyonnais on est content de venir en tant
club pro puisquon vient se se frotter un
petit peu aux équipes parisiennes on n
pas l'habitude de les jouer grosse
intensité à une région parisienne où
vraiment il y a il y a vraiment de bons
joueurs donc pour nous pour faire
progresser nos joueurs sur des matchs de
30 minutes il y a rien de mieux là tout
pendant les vacances donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est là bah c'est un tournoi où on
peut prendre pas mal d'expérience avec
les clubs pro et les autres clubs qu'on
qu'on va pas jouer pendant longtemps
donc le but c'est de prendre de
l'expérience d'essayer de les connaître
et et de et de gagner bien sûr c'est la
première fois on fait un tournoi avec
des
Champions
et on voit que il faut encore travailler
pour bah pour être à ce niveau à la fin
du tournoi c'est le Club de Bruges qui a
soulevé la coupe pour la deuxème fois
après l'édition 2021 la première équipe
ivinoise boifffle termine 9e et plaisir
15e de ce rendez-vous vu le succès
rencontré cette année une 4e édition
déjà programmée pour l'année prochaine
et bien merci michelll pour ces
informations sportives c'est bientôt
l'heure de l'invité du 78 mais avant ça
je vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à
la météo de
demain et Bonne Nouvelle demain matin
nous devrions rester au sec si le ciel
reste nuageux des éclairciss sont prévus
toute la journée côté température compé
11°gr à Versailles et rambouillé et
12°gr à Oudan et Mantel jolie
l'après-midi même tendance avec une
légère hausse des températures comprise
entre 13°gr à rambouiller et 15°gr à
Mantel jolie c'est l'heure à présent de
passer à l'invité du
[Musique]
78 chaque année le département des
ivelines mène deux enquêtes annuelles
sur l'activité t touristique de son
territoire rendu public il y a quelques
jours le bilan estival est positif et en
nette amélioration par rapport à 2022
avec nous Joséphine colmans berger
vice-présidente du département délégué à
la culture et au tourisme on imagine que
c'est une bonne nouvelle une excellente
nouvelle après ces années que nous avons
pu vivre qui ont été des années assez
compliquées et on se demandait même si
on allait redémarrer bien sûr et là on
s'est rendu compte avec cette petite
enquête enfin petite enquête on va être
non grande enquête euh mais en tout cas
on s'est rendu compte que oui c'est
positif et les retours sont très bons
justement cette enquête c'est des
documents des questionnaires qui sont
donnés aux acteurs du tourisme qu'est-ce
qui est ressorti de ces enquêtes alors
ce qui est ressorti c'est que il y a il
y a vraiment un un essort euh je dirais
un retour déjà de d'une clientèle même
étrangère puisqu'on s'est rendu compte
que on revoit maintenant et bien des des
des gens qui viennent de Belgique
d'Angleterre d'Allemagne donc tout ça
c'est plutôt une bonne chose on s'est
rendu compte également que l'offre
touristique au niveau professionnel
refonctionne également donc ça c'est
plutôt ça veut dire qu'il y a un
développement économique qui se remet
vraiment dans le circuit on s'est rendu
compte également que tout ce qui est
environnemental est très fort puisque
vous savez qu'on a pu développer 1700 km
sur l'ensemble du département de piste à
la fois équestre piéton et cycliste qui
a permis justement de faire revenir
aussi tout toutes ces personnes-là et et
on s'est aperçu que bien sûr les les
restaurateurs sont aussi dans une
démarche je dirais plutôt positive et se
rendent compte que le département reste
reste toujours quelque chose de très
fort je veux dire au niveau au niveau de
de la pétence des touristes vous parliez
des visiteurs étrangers qui reviennent
c'était important après la crise du
covid oui c'était fondamental puisque
c'est vrai que le gros de notre de notre
clientèle touristique on va les appeler
comme ça c'est surtout l'île- de- France
les ivelines elles-mêmes mais
l'île-de-fance mais on a aussi beaucoup
d'étrangers bien sûr dans la balance
nous avons le château de Versailles
Château de versaill bien sûr qui compte
énormément plus avec une Haus de 13 %
cette Ann exactement de 13 % c'est vrai
que on peut pas comptabiliser uniquement
le château de Versailles mais à côté de
ça on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
vraiment un apport étranger qui revenait
et ça on en est ravi surtout les pays
asiatiques qui s'étaient complètement
bloqué pendant la période de covid alors
vous parliez justement du château de
Versailles l'actualité a été difficile
ces derniers temps avec les nombreuses
fausses alertes à la bombe est-ce que
vous craignez que ça impacte le tourisme
ça l'impacte forcément aujourd'hui on se
rend compte et on a des informations par
des offices de tourisme d'abandon bien
sûr d'inquiétude par rapport à cette
situation actuellement tout ce qu'on
peut voir bien sûr sont sont des choses
très anxiogènes et le fait d'avoir 5 si
évacuations du château de versaill
forcément inquiète la population c'est
sûr alors il y a le château de
Versailles qui est très touristique dans
les ivines mais le département a choisi
de mettre en valeur également la scène
pour étauffer son offre touristique et
tout ce qui peut se faire autour
pourquoi c'était important de la mettre
en avant parce que la scène et bien
pendant des décennies même même plus que
ça et bien les villes tournaient le dos
à la scène tout a été construit d'une
autre façon et il est clair que
aujourd'hui et bien on se rend compte
que c'est une richesse incroyable c'est
à la fois une richesse touristique bien
évidemment mais c'est une richesse à
développement économique également donc
aujourd'hui on est en train de faire des
réaménagement très importants au niveau
de la scène qui sont des pardon des
réaménagements qui sont dans une
continuité même avec tous les
départements limitrophes hein
c'est-à-dire en amont et en aval pour
pouvoir développer les pistes cyclables
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure qui
sont des pistes importantes comme la
vélocénie par exemple on a on a des
pistes qui partent de Paris qui vont
jusque jusqu'au Havre et aussi jusqu'à
Londres donc aujourd'hui on est dans
cette démarche-l et on sait aussi que il
y a des ports qui sont actuellement en
en
réhabilitation parce qu'on a des
croisiéristes très importants qui
viennent s'implanter sur notre
territoire vous avez également
l'initiative d'un tourisme plus durable
alors ça va un petit peu avec ce que
vous avez ce que vous nous avez expliqué
qu'est-ce que ça signifie aujourd'hui un
tourisme plus durable alors ça veut dire
que déjà le département des ivelines
développe également une protection
environnementale vous savez qu'on a
énormément de d'espac naturel sensible
sur le département et non seulement on
doit nous les préserver mais on doit
aussi les améliorer donc on accompagne
également au niveau de nos acteurs
touristiques des aménagements qui sont
des aménagements qui permettent d'avoir
aussi quel je dirais un fonctionnement
beaucoup plus euh durable oui de
transition écologique par exemple
l'écopaturage ça c'est quelque chose que
l'on développe dans certains endroits
mais aussi il y a des récupérateurs
d'eau par exemple pour les toilettes
enfin bref on le département est
vraiment à côté de des acteurs pour
pouvoir les accompagner financièrement
aussi dans ce développement là pour
valoriser le tourisme Joséphine colmans
berger la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat ainsi que le département
lance la 2uxe édition du label artisan
du tourisme est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce que c'est ah oui alors ça
c'est une très belle initiative l'année
dernière nous avons pu distribuer une
trentaine de labels qui étaient des
labels justement qui nous permettaient
de mettre en valeur et et et surtout
dans la lumière des artisans que nous
avons vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
bière j'ai
entendu c'est vrai voilà exactement bien
sûr qu'on a des brasseurs on a pas que
ça on a du chocolatiers et on a aussi
des artistes qui travaillent un
artisanat je dirais presque en voie de
disparition et donc l'année dernière il
y avait un concours et qui permettait de
les mettre à l'honneur donc il y a une
une grande réception qui nous a permis
non seulement de les présenter en détail
mais également et bien de leur offrir se
l'appel du département et on est ravi de
pouvoir le refaire cette année c'est
façon de mettre aussi en avant le
savoir-faire ivelinois exactement le
savoir-faire ivelinois moi je dirais
même le savoir-faire français parce que
ça touche aussi je dirais tout ce qu'on
sait faire dans notre pays on a beaucoup
beaucoup de qualité et c'est important
d'accompagner ces ces artisans parce que
ce sont des entreprise très souvent qui
demande des investissements à la fois
personnels et financiers assez lourds et
donc est important que on leur permett
d'avoir une belle vitrine pour pouvoir
et bien se faire connaître et vendre
vivre très rapidement pour terminer
quels vont être les objectifs pour 2024
euh anné années Jeux Olympiques donc
forcément on va tout faire pour bien
accueillir bienô tous ces touristes qui
vont venir profiter des jeux olympiques
dans notre territoire qui est bien
accompagné par des sports comme vous le
savez sur vraiment dans notre proximité
donc on va tout faire pour que ce soit
bien que les les gens soient heureux
qu'ils soient nombreux qui remplissent
tous nos hôtels tous nos restaurants et
qu'ils reviennent après bien sûr et bien
merci beaucoup à Joséphine col verger
d'avoir répondu à nos questions c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission merci pour
votre fidélité on vous retrouve demain
pour une nouvelle édition en attendant
très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78